talk about your relationship with kevin
gates i know it's a close one gates i
feel like
has always embraced um the younger
generation and
try to you know yeah co-sign certain
people yeah
um how's y'all's relationship how did it
start man oh
my big brother a lot oh
i ain't a lot from the from the very
beginning he didn't
like help me with my career in like ways
he didn't even know like
me and g we had a song called iphone 6
like it's one of our hottest
vr songs he shared it to his store
like roses up you know what i'm saying
right
just just he always like i ain't like he
just always been like motivational like
you know what i'm saying when i was in
jail like
i wrote on like when i come home i'm
like i'm getting it like you know what
i'm saying
here write me like right before i can't
pray for me send me a long prayer you
feel me
so he was actually writing you in jail
like he was like
on the phone so you had the instagram
you were talking about kevin gates
riding you
um he's you know i feel like
every time he hangs out with someone
they become muslim for a few months
did he did he try to get you to you know
participate in the uh in the uh
islamic faith oh i wouldn't i wouldn't
say that i wouldn't say that
am i tripping though or is that true
you'll see people around kevin gates
then all of a sudden
they're muslim and i'm like oh they must
have been around kevin gates i'm gonna
say his character
and and his energy makes you
want to be involved with it with it you
feel me i'm gonna say that so i feel
like a lot of people gravitate to his
images you'll be like yo i [ __ ] with
your energy
and then you associate that with maybe
his his his faith
it's like it's like i'm trying to try to
find a way to put it right you haven't
like noticed like
in history people that like just have a
like people just gravitate to them yeah
for some reason yeah for sure you know
what i'm saying like they got that gift
he's got that uh quality for sure he got
people who want to be just like him
yeah so they're going to do things like
him and stuff like that but
when i on i did go to the what is called
the um
mosque i did go i did go there with him
i told him i was like i i
i i'm not gonna do that yeah i i just
stayed at the door and i like
but i i really liked it i'm gonna pull
up with you you know i haven't been
around it like in jail like
but i'm really strict of my religious
beliefs like what are your religious
beliefs i believe in god and that's it
so you consider yourself christian
baptist i just believe in
i i used to be baptised but i believe in
god right
so no bible like no paper like it's just
you know what that i
respect it's just simple as that like
it's just like you believe in a higher
power
yeah like because when you get into okay
which religion here you know it gets you
you get a headache just thinking about
this well i also think too that
a lot of people should i i'm personally
like i'm atheist but
i feel like i i i i really could like
see it on you i really believe in like
like if you told me what's more real
aliens or you know heavens in the sky
i'm [ __ ] running with the aliens dog
all day you know what i'm saying but
like personally
but you had a right because like it's
like i want to believe in something that
i could see
and i i can i want to believe in things
that make sense and i feel and and i
feel like
but over the history of our world
religion has been the biggest divider
and has caused all the wars right and
everybody is not right
and it's man-made right a lot of these
religions
they're all written books are written by
i don't believe in man so
i respect that you cannot believe if you
don't believe
everything a human says you cannot
believe in the bible i think that means
that you're
you're agnostic technically you believe
in a higher power you just don't
identify i don't identify like i say god
but
what is it then he's spiritual yeah
you're spiritual not religious
yeah okay that's fair this is like
like for one like if you just if you
just like take little things and just
really pay attention like slavery right
you go to slavery
nah they didn't want us
to know how to read so what they did
i'm gonna get this one person that does
know how to read and i'm gonna make him
read you what i want you to read not
i'm not about to give you what you need
to know you fear me
and that's and what you just said so why
the [ __ ] would i believe
what you just said to me is is religious
it's religion
right it's it's it's used to uh control
the vulnerable
so how do we trouble used to control
society how do we know that all these
religions wouldn't
make just for that that's what it's for
that's what it's for
no it's it's the biggest hypocritical
horseshit ever like
you know if you think of like listen man
i just
i i respect someone who says they're
christian because like hey whatever
makes you
whole at night and you know but i just
think that religion in general is
something that
is very easy to point out clearly the
bad that it's contributed to that i
respect everybody
but like it's just like just like
then like with the muslim thing like i
respect them dudes like you
know for sure with a lot of them me too
but a lot of those
people i was in jail joined muslim
justice protection
like a lot of people like i'm talking
about like they really over here trying
to learn a whole different language
for protection so [ __ ] won't get on the
ass you know you feel me
[ __ ] so wait so were the muslims in your
jail was it like
was it low-key like if you were like a
part of that crew everyone had each
other's back like uh
like oh and what were you locked up in
in in
louisiana yeah okay because you don't go
out of state unless you federal
right right right right but um well i
did do
to some camps out of state but it's
really illegally but
i'll stay [ __ ] up down go [ __ ] right
but um
yeah like some people like they will say
their mothers in them and their
you know i don't know you know that's
crazy shout out to i mean like i said
man i respect everyone's
viewpoints i just have my own yeah he um
like he he he invited me to i went in
like just uh
because i i i hadn't been around it but
i haven't been asked
to a actual one right right so it was
like i like the experience things you
hear me so it was like a good experience
and stuff
yeah of course that's the way i am like
he don't
he he's not he's not about to try to
make you be
something you know what i'm saying it's
just people
people like gravitate to his energy he
got he got a
the being around him is it's a good fit
like we i don't know if you remember the
moment where he told the interviews to
stop touching him
that was me and dj head's interview
[Laughter]
and it was the most intense like
20 minutes of our life and then after
the interview
it went super viral obviously and we
were like what the [ __ ] just happened
because he just got well he just got out
of jail like six months earlier
but but i'm like he let his guard down
after the interview finished and we
talked for like an hour
he played us his album and he was like
he was like [ __ ] man
if i don't know y'all like i wish i
would have known y'all but
like we would have had a much better
interview because i [ __ ] with y'all
because i'm like that with interviews
too is like
i come like i'm always going to be kind
of hissing with people
like but you make me feel comfortable
okay
i can i could it's going to be a good
interview well plus it's also
on you know i think too like i don't
[ __ ] with that touching [ __ ] either
though
i didn't my biggest pet peeve is when
you're talking to me
and you like yo fam like hey fam yeah
that [ __ ] is like no no i feel it like
like it's just like now dj has to touch
her okay